got dressed out of high school right I
don't know how you guys do that like
mentally and physically I just didn't
feel like I was ready yet you're not I
wasn't when I got drafted I wasn't I
decided purely based off the money I got
like I was calling my boys calling my
mom calling Bree crying like I'm not
ready for this your 18 year old kid you
just went from high school so you with
everybody two weeks ago yeah and then
you go to a place where I don't know
anybody and then you get a whole bunch
of money you don't know how to really
act and what you just said right there
like I think that's the biggest
difference I saw in a lot of the high
school guys and college guys that made
it through a mid to the major leagues
was they had a support system and they
had people around them family friends
that kind of said hey knucklehead knock
that off man because I had so many
friends like you said get drafted you
make a lot of money also they're buying
everything they want they're forgetting
about investing like all sudden they're
done in a couple years they got a high
school diploma they got no more money
it's tough man but like you said like
I'm thankful we both have great parents
and just people around us